♪ ♪ ♪
- Une opération escargot sur un
grand axe routier aux Pays-Bas
l'été dernier; les tracteurs
provoquent des bouchons
monstres. Sur l'autoroute, la
colère des agriculteurs s'étale.
C'est un plan, dévoilé au mois
de juin, qui a mis le feu aux
poudres : le pays devra diminuer
de 50 % ses rejets d'azote
d'ici 2030. Pour y arriver,
le gouememement a annoncé
qu'il faudrait réduire de près
du tiers le nombre d'animaux
d'agagage. Dans un pays aux
profondes racines agricoles,
la nouvelle crée une commotion.
ututut au long de l'été,
les manifestations se succèdent.
♪ ♪ ♪
Trienke Elshof est productrice
laitière et travaille aussi pour
le plus grand syndicat agricole
des Pays-Bas.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Cette étable est conçue pour
300 vaches. Nous en avons
250 en ce momeMaMaMais si on
n'en garde que 200, par exemple,
on a encore les coûts pour
tout le bâtiment, les emprunts
à la banqIlIlIl va falloir
faire des calculs. On ne sait
pas si ce sera possible.
- Alors que le reste du monde
parle de diminuer ses émissions
de carbone, ici, l'urgence,
c'est aussi de réduire
les émissions azotées.
On vise entre autres
le protoxyde d'azote,
un gaz à effet de serre 300 fois
plus puissant que le CO2.
Il provient des excès d'engrais
et de fumier. L'ammoniac est
également ciblé. Il est aussi
généré par les déjections
animales.
♪ ♪ ♪
Aux Pays-Bas, le secteur
agricole est responsable de plus
de 60 % des émissions d'azote.
L'objectif du gouvernement
est de s'attaquer rapidement
aux fermes les plus polluantes.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
À court terme, le gouvernement
nous dit qu'il faudra éliminer
de 500 à 600 fermes.
L'État devra les acheter pour
qu'elles ne produisent plus.
- Le gouvernement a débloquéprps
pour la transition.
- Pour les Pays-Bas,
c'est un changement de cap
radical. Après avoir souffert
de la faim pendant la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale, les Néerlandais
se sont dit : "Plus jamais!"
Et ils ont tenu parole.
Ce pays minuscule de 17 millions
d'habitants est aujourd'hui
le deuxième exportateur agricole
en valeur au monde, après
les États-Unis. Et le chept
national reflète cette réalité.
C'est la plus forte densité
d'animaux d'élevage de l'Europe:
4 millions de bovins,
12 millions de porcs,
100 millions de poulets.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
La viande et le lait sont
exportés, mais le fumier reste
ici. C'est ça, le problème.
Notre secteur agricole est
beaucoup trop important.
Nos champs n'ont pas
la capacité d'absorber tout ça.
- Ce professeur retraité
de la plus grande université
agricole du pays explique
qu'on a trop tardé à agir.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Les premières politiques pour
résoudre le problème datent
des années 80, mais elles ont
été un échec.
- Aujourd'hui, les niveaux
de pollution azotée dépassent
beaucoup les normes européennes.
Pour Trienke,
dont les deux fils voudraient
reprendre la ferme, la réalité
d'aujourd'hui est aux antipodes
de celle qu'elle a connu il
y a quelques décennies à peine.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Nous sommes passés
de 140 à 250 vaches en 30 ans.
La ferme pouvait grossir,
se développer. Nos enfants,
x,x,x, doivent penser à réduire,
réduire. C'est très différent.
- Ici Catherine Mercier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.